what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
bryson by n l e choppa
but before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're gonna be notified
of my daily videos
okay so just you guys know i like
i'm not a big like rap music fan so it's
interesting to like
see this and kind of compare it to like
the country music videos that i normally
watch
[Music]
[Music]
okay
all right
everybody
[Music]
he said i was special knew that [ __ ]
that was for certain i would've thought
this world was perfect
but it came with some curses i read
between the verses if the truth you been
searching
who is bryson i'm assuming that's like
the main character
in this song that's what i'm gonna
assume but he's basically just saying
that he
since he's been born you know he's just
always been
a cool guy he's been special and headed
on to like good
i'm alerted i was feeling like a servant
i ain't a part of this circus my soul
been overworking she can't handle my
burden but she say she wanna birth it i
fell asleep in churches i ain't know
what he was cursing within myself i got
faith in prayer start unfolding i know
that god
okay that's really cool so he's like
watching back his childhood
that's a really creative and cool idea
[Music]
okay that is not safe oh that is not
sick oh my gosh
i will feel real scared like dancing on
that ledge
like that and i've been feeling
righteous i'm going through
enlightenment
clutches of a sidekick in between her
like hyphens they staying on no [ __ ] but
wait till it hit the fan
grounding up in the sand the word put in
i seen
i'm a bigger man better man i got a
better plan if you
understand what somebody with some
understanding pinot gland in my crown
and i got the oven
with the blues and rubber bands i
attract abundance affirmations daily
that's why blisses keep on coming in
369 when i wake i write it three times
six times in the day time
nine at night time wait what did he just
say let me go back hold up
let's just keep on coming in three six
nine when i wake i write it three times
six times in the daytime nine at
nighttime
oh that was clever so he said three six
nine he writes his
affirmations wait three times in the
daytime and like nine times at night
that was
i think i butchered that but that was
cool thoughts into your heart it'll
change your dna negative thoughts they
fall apart not a [ __ ] think it's
straight i don't even smoke weed no more
i'll put that on the heavens
speaking on the heavens gates i know i'm
going to heaven may i never thought i'd
say this but i'm eating on the vegan
plate
don't take me to chick-fil-a i'm meeting
at the grand cafe they ain't open on
sunday anyway
[ __ ] your dinner date you are what you
eat i'm counting green eating celery
okay so he's just basically talking
about how he doesn't smoke weed anymore
he doesn't
eat like bad foods like he's eating
vegetables
that's a good message i can't argue with
that i personally don't really like
vegetables but
you know adios thinkers say still
florida biz lord silpay got you out of
shape distractions all in your face they
tell me when they gonna wait
donald trump the last president ain't no
more candidates backyard to farmland but
grew up watching gang land
on the block hanging i had my drinks
if you put in you get it back that's
dangerous feel like all my coma came
back when i got famous
put the good in you get the good out i
don't even told my gun no mo
cause i'm knowing that i'm good now
universe keep working for me ain't
nobody gonna touch me they say protect
chop it off cause they need to change
[Music]
are they just throwing out money are
they crazy
oh no i would not
[Music]
i'm too cheap for that nope
[Music]
wow
[Music]
that's a bold move i would not just go
up to
[Music]
oh he's just gonna let him go now
damn
that was actually a really well put
together and very cute music video like
i thought that idea was so clever of him
like looking back
as like an adult at his at his childhood
i thought that was so cool
um i'm just rant this song a four out of
five
i really like i really liked that video
too
but let me know what you guys think in
the comments
and let me know what video i should
react to next do not forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time